[Música]
desde muito cedo eu aprendi a observar
religião como um fenômeno paradoxal
complexo hamburgo às vezes violento e
muitas vezes sem sentido crianças
aprendi não se convertem as religiões de
forma racional de forma burocrática e
nem fazem experiência religiosa a partir
das instituições do sagrado daquelas que
acreditam que podem controlar a fé das
pessoas crianças ficcionam a realidade
fazem do poético do lúdico e do
imaginativo tanto um caminho de
aprendizagem da realidade como de
interpretação da realidade e as minhas
primeiras experiências com a religião
foram desta forma
mediados por uma espécie de encantamento
sabe é mediados por um puro encantamento
com os mistérios das relações humanas
mediadas por um por um e citação e por
um medo diante dos ritos e diante das
fórmulas míticas e místicas sabe que eu
fui criado numa família muito plural a
minha mãe uma mulher evangélica
pentecostal
já a sina dos anjos o meu pai nem nos
deuses do futebol acreditava naquela
época o meu avô era um católico nominal
ea minha avó uma católica especial sabe
assim bem praticante devota e da legião
de maria maria josé
minha avó da legião de maria e nesse
ambiente diverso é um ambiente de muitas
formas de crescer muitas formas de não
crê
eu aprendi a observar o que seria o
fenômeno religioso e como ele acontecia
tanto no coração das pessoas como nas
formas sociais institucionais da
religião
eu lembro por exemplo que quando a minha
mãe me levava propor o culto aos
domingos no domingo era dia de jesus na
cabeça da minha vida da minha mãe e ela
me levava para o culto aos domingos eu
chegava nessas reuniões
eu ficava vendo o pessoal cantando assim
muito loucamente chorando
nada encantado com tudo aquilo que
estava acontecendo el lembro que tinha
também um homem que fazia um discurso
longuíssimo assim mais de 50 minutos
fazendo o que os evangélicos chamam de
pregação e de seu irmão eu fico
imaginando colocar um homem que está
acostumado a falar por uma hora diante
do relógio desse 18 minutos deve ser uma
coisa muito louca e eu não gostava eu
achava estranho como é que a gente pode
ficar sentado na frente de uma pessoa
que fala por uma hora sem fim e no final
o pessoal ainda aplaudia sabe eu ficava
olhando assim vocês vão conhecer o
pessoal e todo mundo gostava daquilo ele
aquele ambiente era muito emocionante e
às terças feiras o dia que a legião de
maria transformava a varanda da minha
avó numa pequena catedral sabe num
pequeno espaço sagrado eu eu chegava da
escola
depois de assistir chave sempre tem
chave depois da escola e aí eu descia a
escada da minha mãe assim muito muito
escondido sabe com medo essa não sei o
que está acontecendo os mistérios e eu
ficava espreitado escondido entre as
plantas da minha avó para ficar
observando as liturgias da legião de
maria e eu achava aquilo
além de muito pedagógico muito
encantador era muito excitante está no
espaço onde as muitas crenças e onde as
muitas não crenças conviviam e eu lembro
que no final elas sempre rezavam o pai
nosso pai nosso que estais no céu todos
vocês devem conhecer ou já ouviram
alguém orar
dessa forma alguma vez mas ali na
reunião da minha avó elas também rezava
a ave maria e era diferente porque por
exemplo na região da minha mãe da igreja
evangélica eles se referiam a deus
sempre como pai na forma masculina já na
religião da minha avó
além de referir se a deus como pai
existiam esses santos e santas existiu
santas femininas e existia essa
invocação de maria então na religião da
minha avó viu espaço pra pra deuses e
deuses e eu ficava sempre comparando
estas duas realidades sabe sempre muito
encantado com essa diversidade
mas eu cresci num bairro pobre de uma
cidade
pobre da região metropolitana do rio de
janeiro bairro almerinda são gonçalo rio
de janeiro e lá na minha vizinhança
também havia muita diversidade muito a
pluralidade religiosa os meus vizinhos
na sua maioria negros e negras ou eram
de um tipo de catolicismo um pouco mais
dançante que zombeteiro africano que o
da minha avó ou eram da umbanda e do
candomblé e muitos dos meus vizinhos
praticavam essa diversidade de crenças
criavam esse mosaico de religião ali ao
meu redor e naquela residência naquele
lugar naquela vizinhança pobre os meus
vizinhos me ensinaram que onde a pobreza
precariedade vulnerabilidade
há também muita solidariedade entre os
viventes e assim uma espécie de fé forte
de uma fé alegre que os inspira a
suportar a resistir ea reinventar a vida
ali naquela situação de vulnerabilidade
às periferias do brasil são religiosas
os lugares onde as pessoas sofrem são
lugares de religião porque é preciso
muita fé alegre para suportar as lutas
do cotidiano
mas até aí você pode dizer são
experiências interessantes bonitas e
divertidas até mas eu passo pelas minhas
primeiras experiências com o lado negro
nefasto e violento com a da religião e
duas experiências marcaram profundamente
o início da minha adolescência nesse
aspecto
a primeira se deu no dia em que eu
estava lendo um livro de história das
religiões no brasil e eu comecei a
enxergar e inimizades entre católicos e
protestantes
eu passava cada página do livro que eu
passava enxergava uma inimizade entre
católica e protestante inimizade entre
católicos e protestantes na irlanda e
inimizade entre católica e protestante
em londres inimizade entre católica e
protestante no nordeste brasileiro e
inimizade entre católica e protestante
no norte do meu estado rio de janeiro
quando eu olhava o livro e via essas
inimizades e olhava pra minha casa minha
mãe evangélica convivendo com a minha
avó católica bem pacificamente com
passivamente
eu balançado esses dois conflitos aqui
eu ficava um pouco perdido esse paradoxo
segundo acontecimento foi quando eu
voltava da escola de novo já anoitecendo
quando eu vi a polícia militar do rio de
janeiro
agredindo os meus vizinhos da umbanda e
do candomblé
eu lembro que eles estavam fazendo um
ritual na quase na rua da minha casa e
daí a polícia fez uma batida fez uma
blitz e os acusou de macumbaria de
feitiçaria e começou a tratá los na sua
experiência de fé como se eles fossem
criminosos
aquilo mexeu muito comigo seria religião
crime crer seria uma doença é possível
criminalizar a fé do outro e eu comecei
a fazer essas perguntas essas coisas me
inquietaram profundamente principalmente
porque por exemplo a religião da minha
mãe podia usar os espaços públicos para
fazer os encontros e celebrações
as igrejas evangélicas e católicas
podiam se reunir nas praças pôde ocupar
as ruas e porque os meus vizinhos da
umbanda e do candomblé estavam sendo
tratados como criminosos a usar o espaço
público para professar sua fé
depois eu descobri que há uma vinculação
profunda entre o nosso preconceito
latente à violência institucional eo
racismo que transforma experiências de
fé em crime em loucura em doença
foi assim no rio de janeiro há muitas
histórias sobre isso mas foi possível
superar essas experiências foi possível
conhecer as razões ideológicas políticas
filosóficas históricas por trás desses
conflitos que eu estou lhes
compartilhando e foi possível a partir
da pesquisa do estudo e foi a partir
disso que eu fiz do estudo da pesquisa
da investigação um caminho para
compreender os paradoxos das religiões
no brasil
o primeiro desafio o desafio que eu
gostaria de propor para vocês quando a
gente observa o fenômeno religioso é que
a gente seja capaz
e não apenas julgar as religiões pelas
suas formas institucionais porque essa é
uma questão
pergunta-se o que é religião você já
pensa em padre pastor igreja livro
sagrado lugar sagrado dia sagrado templo
os sacerdotes quando pergunta se sobre
religião na maioria das vezes comumente
a gente responde com as formas
institucionais da religião com as
burocracias da religião ou referindo nos
as instituições religiosas mas as formas
institucionais da religião as
burocracias da religião não contemplou
não encerram e não explicam totalmente o
fenômeno religioso e aqui está um
paradoxo importante é compartilhar com
vocês nós precisamos de uma noção de
religião de uma de uma forma de entender
e de aprender religião diferente
nós precisamos de uma forma de
compreender religião que dê conta da
complexidade da pluralidade ea
diversidade dos fenômenos religiosos que
acontece ao nosso redor
e daí
quando a gente olha para além da
religião como essa forma de dominação
como essa forma de poderem positivo
sobre o outro
aí a gente usa o paradoxo pra pensar
religião surge uma outra maneira
uma outra maneira de olhar uma outra
maneira de sentir e interpretar religião
que eu gostaria de chamar aqui de
religião enquanto potência para a vida
se por um lado existe a religião que
domina que controla que disciplina que
regula por outro existe a religião como
uma potência de viver como essa energia
subjetiva como essa vitalidade do ser
humano que dá sentido à sua vida e
organiza as suas relações organiza as
relações ao redor se existem igrejas
oprimidos se existem doutrinas oprimindo
existem formas novas de se relacionar
formas novas de conviver a partir dessa
potência que surge da subjetividade
humana e dá sentido à sua existência se
é possível falar no brasil
de um poder religioso que violenta
também é possível falar no brasil de um
poder religioso que dá liberdade
criatividade que impulsiona e que nos e
que nos inspira viveu uma vida melhor
não só subjetivamente maggi nas nossas
relações de amor e de convivência mais
próximo
nesse sentido a amizade é uma nova
religião nesse sentido o abraço é uma
nova religião o amor a convivência
pluralidade a diversidade são novas
formas de religião são potências de vida
que mão do nosso coração do nosso peito
do nosso afeto ea gente derrama sobre os
outros e outros que convivem com a gente
religião não é só poder não é só poderá
denominar de dominar a religião também é
potência de viver potência de
compartilhar e aí pensando na infância
novamente como esse lugar privilegiado
de se pensar a religião
eu lembro que infância é brinquedo
infância é jogar com símbolos jogar com
linguagens e religião poderia ser
infância nesse sentido de jogar com
símbolos jogar com linguagens e agora eu
lembro por exemplo da minha filha lara
da infância mais revolucionário da minha
vida e da vida menor vida mais frágil
vida mais forte e frágil vida que mudou
radicalmente a minha vida e eu lembro
que eu terei a oportunidade de educar a
minha filha e de ser exemplo para ela de
que é possível conviver na diversidade
eu quero ensinar lara que religião pode
ser um modo novo de conviver que
religião pode ser um modo novo de
compreender de incluir o outro as suas
diversidades as suas singularidades num
abraço generoso eu quero ensinar minha
filha que é possível surgir ir além
dessa religião como dominação pra pensar
religião como uma relação nova como um
jeito de construir novas relações
ensinar a lara
há inclusive superar os muito
os preconceitos que agridem a nossa
diversidade humana
compartilhando com ela de que na
diversidade e na convivência generosa e
na possibilidade de trocar abraços
beijos num ambiente de diversidade é
possível construir um mundo melhor pra
mim pra você pra todos e todas nós é
possível construir um mundo onde o
plural abit e onde o plural nos
transforme muito obrigado
[Aplausos]